the school system was designed to teach
you to be an employee which is important
or a doctor or a lawyer a specialist but
never about money you've really got to
understand what is risky and what is not
risky and in my world if you play it
safe that makes you stupid because if
you don't take risk you don't get
smarter and when somebody says what is
risk you have to look in the mirror you
know I mean for me to fly in Vietnam
that was high risk but the higher the
risk the more you have to study you know
that I know that well first of all
everybody can do
something but they won't and that's the
problem the point is everybody can do
something but you got to figure out what
you can do poor people say I can't
afford it I can't do that I don't have
time because this an
escape it's an Escape